perform the sacred movements to make Joe
Biden president because we have the
latest season of the Oh a and this one
has an angel octopus yes the Oh a is
back with the season far more cryptic
than the first and thinks story is here
to explain that insane ending and some
of your biggest unanswered questions so
join me in the dance because here we go
the final episode is called overview
this is a nod to the previous episode in
which Pierre Ruskin who was Pete
Campbell in a previous life told Kareem
about the astronauts he says when the
astronauts reached the moon and looked
back on earth they got an overview
something much more than they ever
dreamed they saw something greater than
themselves man always thought that the
prize was reaching the moon but the real
prize was the perspective it gave us
about Earth Pierre believes the house
will offer Kareem such a prize a new
overview / perspective on how everything
in the universe operates but we'll get
into more of that in a bit it's no
wonder that the first shot of the
episode is of a tree trees are found all
throughout the entire season as a
metaphor for the interconnectedness of
our dimensions you can see them in
Nina's apartment the background of the
bookstore and of course when the oay
falls from one in Episode five speaking
of the Oh a she's arrived at Treasure
Island HAP's prison laboratory
conveniently across from another famous
prison
Alcatraz dr. Roberts who has not yet
integrated with Homer and dr. Percy who
I will from now on call HAP wonder if
the oay has di D dissociative identity
disorder anything in di Dee since she's
smoking and taking on the role of Nina a
zhirova Pia Ruskin's Russian girlfriend
who's funding HAP's experiments
surrounding the house at the same time
the kids in bb8 I mean B ba also arrived
at Treasure Island in the alternate
dimension in this dimension Treasure
Island is abandoned allowing the kids to
freely roam inside and search for the Oh
a swapping dimensions again kareem
doesn't seem to be handling the news
that piers dreamers saw him in their
visions and let's talk about those
dreamers for a second in Episode two and
Kareem tracks down Marlow roads in Ex
mi5 who work for Pierre's curry program
as an overlap specialist we find
a little more about what Pierre has been
up to back in the 1920s a group of
psychoanalysts in Germany realized their
patients were dreaming the same dream
[Music]
they dreamt of rivers of blood and
Berlin and men wearing black uniforms
essentially predicting World War two
almost twenty years before it happened
Pierre Ruskin believed that if he could
harness the power the power of the quote
group liminal mind he could predict
significant events throughout history
and that's exactly what he did
he used Marlow and the dreamers to
predict the advent of things like
ride-sharing platforms and blockchain
technology bringing him unprecedented
wealth to continue his endeavors Marlow
Rhodes was his overlap specialist
someone who took in all the dreams to
search for patterns and it was a lot of
dreams
she tells cream that in one night she'd
go through 400 of them until she found a
pattern they couldn't solve a tunnel the
size of a coffin a curved double sided
staircase and a rose stained-glass
window they knew that this pointed to a
specific house in San Francisco so
Pierre had Nina by this allegedly
haunted house through a shell company so
that he could remain anonymous people
believed it to be haunted due to it
being built atop cursed Native American
ground and the fact several construction
workers passed out and went crazy while
building it this of course due to the
poisonous gas seeping into it we find
out about later gas that causes
hallucinations Kareem experiences like
how his friend fula seems to have aged
and the bodies chasing him out of the
ground
since Pierre couldn't solve the problem
of the house he crowd-sourced it
offering financial compensation through
a video game called cue symphony cue
Symphony was essentially a test to lead
players through to the house and
hopefully since they got that far they
would be smart enough to unlock its
secret and he wouldn't get hurt in the
process either physically or legally
Kareem leaves a recording device in an
envelope for Moe he's already given MOA
USB with the Michelle vu and Marlowe
Rhodes videos on it in case something
happens to him before he talks to Pierre
but this recorder implies he taped his
conversation with Pierre and Moe should
have it should something happen to him
at the house fun fact Kareem and Moe
used to be a thing for seven years but
broke up because she wanted a baby and
he didn't a Treasure Island Nina
is dr. Roberts on their way to see HAP
which starts a flood of repressed
memories allowing Homer to emerge and in
that instant he remembers everything and
becomes what elodie calls integrated
essentially being able to harness the
memories of every being you have taken
over integrating both instead of
repressing one there is an irony here
that in season one it was the Oh a who
was blind but this season it's dr.
Roberts blind to homer inside him the
power goes out lighting the area in a
crimson glow foreshadowing danger and
also trapping Homer in the elevator
well this is my floor Nina questions
happy but the house she hired him to
find out why the construction workers
went crazy but she finds out he went
behind her back during his therapy
sessions with Pierre when Pierre was in
a vulnerable unconscious state he
convinced him not to rebuild the house
but to build the game instead HAP was
using Pierre to find out the truth about
the house Nina then demands to see what
her money got her and they ventured to
his lab while Kareem arrives at the
house he rearranges the magnetic disks
on the top floor which are shaped like
the rings of a tree the last one he
places is the centerpiece almost as if
the rings signify a ripple or echo in
Episode seven Nina talks to Elodie the
mysterious woman who acts as a messenger
guide and advisor Elodie is also a
dimension traveler but not much is known
beyond that she explains that an echo
was created between Nina HAP and Homer
when they first traveled binding them
together as some sort of cosmic family
events in one dimension affect the other
dimensions around it as she says they
echo and will conspire to bring people
together to balance things out so in
season one when oay told buck about the
story of her life in another dimension
it started the sequence of events for
bucks counterpart Michelle to start
playing the game and leader to Nina's
house in both dimensions this cosmic
force is bringing them together DOA with
buck and Nina with Michelle but leaving
an echo is very dangerous
you could find yourself in a life you
don't know shattering yourself or you
could wake up and not remember people
that you love if the oay is to escape
this echo completely unharmed
it will mean HAP must come along
with her then there's the fact that dr.
robbert still doesn't know Homer is
within him he'll need help but in order
to do that the oay must free Nina inside
herself by confronting her greatest
trauma the drowning she experienced as a
child it was this near-death experience
that began her two diverging dimensions
in the whole Oh a story itself back at
Treasure Island Homer reveals to Renata
that he's himself again and she frees
him from his cage the irony being that
it was Homer who helped trap Renata in
season 1 hat brings Nina to his hidden
room which contains a pool filled with
dead bodies of his subjects who sprout
plants and flowers HAP believes
something dormant blooms in our brains
and that every human mind contains the
multiverse a Garden of forking paths
within us all just waiting to be
fertilized the flowers that sprout from
them offer glimpses into these other
dimensions when he eats the petals he
experiences there nd ease or near-death
experiences this segment also brings up
one of the main themes of the show how
many deaths are worth the cost of
discovery how far are we willing to go
in order to advance this is shown by the
extent HAP goes for his work and is also
echoed by Pierre in his astronaut
analogy how many astronauts died in our
venture to the moon we also see the
bodies of French Jessie and Stephen in
this dimension they are dead having been
led by the game to the house and
subsequently killed this is also why
Michelle was lured into the house as
well
remember the cosmic energy is trying to
bring those worlds together hence why
the living bodies of these kids are in
one and not the other yet they are both
in the same room but dimensions apart
this also answers the question about BBA
and why the message she received in the
mediums house told her she was the only
one safe to travel that's because this
message was sent from Rachel HAP's
former assistant who knew the bodies of
French Stephen and Jessie were dead when
she ventured into the locked room she
knew that if they traveled they would be
inhabiting dead bodies and she knew what
they look like because the oay showed
her her charcoal drawing the same one
seen here with the revelation of HAP's
plan Nina turns back into prairie this
time strong and not fearful of HAP she
tells him that she's an angel and you
can even make out the angel wings behind
her Marie's life was nothing but hard
blind and adopted and held captive for
years while in the other dimension she
could see had her father and was free
now she is fully integrated each
consciousness and is ready to move on
Kareem goes back to the house and
uncovers an excerpt from TS Eliot's poem
little gidding we shall not cease from
exploration and the end of all our
exploring will be to arrive where we
started and know the place for the first
time he then back tracks and goes
through the well unlocking the gate and
ascending into the real red rose room
now I'm not entirely certain why he does
this but my guess is that in order to
solve the puzzle of the house one must
enter it in a certain order
much like the movements of the dance
must be done in a certain order but I
want to hear your theories below the OE
ventures to the backyard where she finds
the cubes Elodie left her half either he
built ones from her design using Nina's
money or they have somehow grown
meanwhile BBA and the kids follow a to
the same yard where they begin to
perform the movements along with the
robots homer comes to save the day by
punching out HAP but is shot by him in
the process she tells him in the new
dimension he'll have to find her we'll
get to that in a second and I'm
wondering if that has anything to do
with home or traveling dimensions in
search of her like that one with the
weird skin lady was that just a dream or
could it be foreshadowing something else
Kareem opens the window to find the
ohi's angelic body ascending to a new
dimension but before it can fully happen
a dove flies through the portal
disrupting the process and dropping her
into a different dimension and I
mentioned in which these characters are
actors in a show the show we are
watching our dimension
notice how HAP uses his real actor name
on jason isaacs and the always name is
the real actresses named Britt in this
dimension she will forget herself
perhaps a result of the head injury she
receives and a stunt gone wrong and why
she tells Homer to come look for her
it is likely next season he will be the
one to unlock her memory like she did to
him this season Britt's wig is taken off
and we see her short hair which leads me
to believe this is what the Oh a saw
when she died at the hands of the old
night in an airplane in our dimension
traveling first-class to the UK to be on
set for the show the old Knight told her
this would show her her
future after all he also predicts that
she will forget herself and her true
nature another hint that her memory will
be gone next season and for those
wondering the octopus is under the
control of Azrael who is also known as
the angel of death the one responsible
for transporting the souls of the
deceased after death it's his suction
tentacles that gave the oay those marks
on her arm kareem calls for michelle who
had traveled through the portal
previously getting caught in this
dimension she feels drawn to him and
climbs the ladder transporting herself
back to the body of the real michelle
and finally we have steven who chases
after the ambulance we know it's likely
him from the other dimension having been
transported during the dance because he
calls jason isaacs hat this also leads
me to believe we'll see the kids and
bb-8 in this world as well now i tried
to cover the ending as best I could and
I know there are countless other
questions still left on answers about
earlier episodes and the series as a
whole many of those will have to wait
till next season like why did the show
start with the phrase 7 hours and 46
minutes earlier so I want to hear your
theories in the comments below not just
about the last episode but the entire
season and where you think it might be
going I hope you enjoyed my take on it
and please like subscribe and share I'll
be here for more videos so stay tuned
and remember daddy loves you very much